the mule report came out right it's
right the bill bar report exactly the
bar report is out putting that aside
let's fast-forward another year from now
Trump spends a hundred million dollars
on Facebook and Instagram ads targeting
them to the same people legally what
happens if he wins again and he uses
Facebook to target everybody and
suppress the vote in certain communities
and get the vote out and others Facebook
and I'll let him spend a hundred million
dollars again take the money absolutely
yeah they're gonna take it yeah
absolutely and that's fine
I mean no it's not yes they should not
but well that's a question why not
because of micro-targeting you're
opposed to it in advertising yeah to a
certain extent for I mean credit for me
I opted out I don't have a Facebook
account
I do have an Instagram account I rarely
use it I try to be on Twitter as little
as possible so I've kind of taken in you
know for our industry pretty unusual
turn for myself personally like I'm
trying to opt out of social media but no
I mean I look you know Zuckerberg is not
an idiot
he knows how unbelievably toxic this
administration is yeah and yeah to to
enable that to continue that you have a
moral obligation to prevent that from
happening and to create a framework by
which that cannot happen again I think
Zuckerberg is actually a secret
conservative like Andreessen and teal
teal is not secret but I think injury
syns kind of secret Marc Andreessen
probably tell you his politics
yeah he says I think he might secretly
be like a conservative no I think he's
just so repressed
he's a Mitt Romney conservative he's not
a Trump conservative right
I think Zuckerberg I think the general
problem with the Zuckerberg is of the
world in our world is that they don't
it's an inconvenient truth that these
problems exist they didn't sign up for
it right the guy signed up to make a you
know a college network where you could
you know fine find out the relationships
yeah so you know they have this problem
they prefer to not think it exists
they're taking different sort of
begrudging tactics to kind of deal with
these things I don't I don't know what
we're gonna get out of them but I don't
think you can say we're not gonna take
money from this side and we're gonna
take money from this side I think they
could say we're not gonna take money
from anybody because I haven't done the
math but I don't think it's that much
money it would be like 1% of their
revenue yeah that's not so they could
just say look like we're so concerned
about the idea of that would be the way
to do we're not gonna take any of these
things we'll see what they do I think
that that they if they had any guts and
they really wanted to rehabilitate their
horrible image and the lack of trust
people have in the declining nature of
Facebook in America they would just say
we're not gonna take political ads or
they could say you can run a political
ad you cannot target it can't target it
by state or maybe they just make a
top-level target you target by state but
you can't go down to the community level
and you certainly can't do retargeting
and specific ads against specific groups
of people in yeah I tend to think if you
just said we're not gonna allow negative
advertising broadly just for anybody
right so tell everybody how great Trump
is but don't tell everybody how bad the
other guy yeah you can't do a post that
that's an Asian
I mean I've talked to some Facebook
people in general about the idea of
saying like look if you're uncomfortable
with this idea of fake news versus non
fake news let's think about this
accident as a positive versus negative
sentiment because we'd all probably be a
lot happier if we saw more of the
positive stuff and that's the you know
not necessarily a trivial issue but is a
interesting way to think about the
content environments that we're
subjecting people to and how they feel
about themselves afterwards also I got a
crazy crazy idea which I don't know if
they'll take but I was thinking maybe
for the next election
to not allow political ads paid for in
rubles I'm not sure that's gonna fly or
how about not from Cayman Island LLC's
yeah I think they're working on some of
that stuff so supposedly they solved
that problem so but hey really yeah I
think now they now ask for American
identification for any political I mean
to be serious though the real problem
there is like it's not the money spent
on ads we talked about the number money
spent on the ad
but you can spend a lot of money in
creating organic content that's what
people don't understand um so if you
spend twenty million dollars creating
organic content you actually get more
reach with that and the data on this is
pretty dang interesting how do you how
do you deal with that yeah it's not like
you can put disclosures on that you can
just limit ad budgets I mean that's
really I mean I think the state of the
art is to create a series of ads and
themes and then test them with small
dollar amounts and then plow the money
into the winning test obviously which is
what I think they did the wall and lock
her up and a lot of the you know
catchphrases seem to be things that they
tested in the laboratory of a bee
testing you know multivariate testing on
facebook and other places it's just
super sinister when you think about it
ya know it is I mean this is a frame for
our national political environment right
like every campaign is national now and
they all align with these issues and you
can mark micro target everybody so you
can suppress the other guys and try to
enrage your folks so they could